brahim the boxer donc on va faire une
interview dernier co c'est normal on a
beau cheval rouge pendant le qinghai on
ne bouge pas vraiment de rigueur
braly le dernier coup de tête classé
soir ouais dernier coup de coeur le
suppose que je viens de faire
ouais pour l'éducation nationale pour le
respect pour les gens c'est vrai dernier
coup de poing le 8 octobre à paris
pendant les 2 puis il ya pas eu de coup
de poing non je sors le ring comme génie
sur le fruit d'un les coups de folie de
monter sur un ring
c'est une folie dernier coup de foudre
ont d'abord un joker joker un joker donc
c'est la personne à côté qui répond
c'est la loi ici je suis un dernier coup
de foot vous de venir dans votre
émission
mais si j'arrêtais de mathworks
maintenance tout va bien de tourner
enfin rencontrer très bien et voilà les
good food et le dit busch annonçons la
guitare
c'est bizarre oui c'est bizarre bizarre
et bien vers les coups de gueule l'agent
la situation ah bon ouais ben majid pas
ces gens vont passer un consanguine et
de sujets discutés moi ouais
j'étais je dirais ce thème si l'argent
réel risque était bien placé pour dire
sa vérité
man a pris naissance dans le combat